We we can walk down every talking point
you could potentially give and it's all
[__] [__] It's all total
[__] [music]
What standards is Ethan after living up
to?
None. There are no standards for Ethan.
It was going to happen any day, so why
not Ethan? What's wrong with Ethan doing
it? [__] idiot. Don't piss off rich,
powerful, spiteful people. That's not
the justification. He's just doing it
cuz he doesn't like that group of
people. Don't criticize Ethan Klein
while reacting to his [music] content.
That's the social standard they set.
It's only a short line in the box video.
It's only about 16 minutes long.
But I did, guys, full disclosure,
I watched the first few minutes of this
video
when I first woke up yesterday
and it made me so angry,
I immediately DM'd Lone Wolf Box and I
said I linked this video. I said, "This
is a terrible video. You sound [__]
whenever you talk about Ethan these
days. Talk to Peisko."
And he said, "Are we going on live and
learn next week?" So it seems I'll
probably bring up then bring it up then.
I said, "God bless." Thank you for the
five gift of all. You appreciate it.
So, we're going to take a look at this,
okay? Let's take a look.
Moral frogging about the Casey Tron
who seriously sincerely believes even
when
>> we do love Lone Wolf Box though. We do
love Lone Wolf Box. Okay, regardless,
it's just this Ethan stuff. Apparently
he's had some [__] takes on the
Venezuela stuff too, which we'll see.
We'll get into that at some point. I
don't know if we'll do it tonight,
probably tomorrow. But I will watch that
Peisko debate when it happens.
>> is [__] playing Warcraft and just
[__] having videos on in the
background and not pausing that often.
Even that was like way above and beyond
anything Casey Tron was doing. She just
literally she [__] just leaves videos
on. Here's But I did have breakfast.
[music] But I did have breakfast. Who
Who is we? Who loves Lone and Lone Wolf
Box? All of us. We love Lone Wolf Box.
We love Lone.
as to what we care about, right? So I'm
The reason why I'm isolating this and
giving you a
>> understand what Peisko wants from this.
Um
Peisko is he's correct in a in pointing
out that when Ethan said that this was
to protect copyright or set precedent
that it has to be malicious intent.
Otherwise like that doesn't really make
any sense to me because obviously you
don't need any malicious intent to sue
people. Uh it makes sense in a moral
way. Like as a moral argument it's okay
to say that like yeah, I think in in
this social circle it's probably okay to
have a standard that someone is
maliciously talking about stealing
content or from depriving you of views
like intentionally then it's you should
probably have less sympathy for them
when they do it. Um
It's So so that's like worthless. That's
like
He's just gone from
So he's switched between two positions
there, right? So he says Peisko's right
about the legal point. Okay, cool.
Moves on. Right? So he's saying it's
fine to have his first position that
he's laying out is it's fine to set a
social precedent that malicious
reactions are not allowed.
But he doesn't actually fulfill that
position. He starts saying that and then
we shift into this this total [__]
non-position that is just like not a not
an opinion, not an argument, not worth
[__] It's the sort of thing that his
his father would do on if he was on
Piers Morgan trying to sound edgy but
not giving actual actual take.
Sort of that it sounds a lot like his
father in many points in this video.
I've got to be honest. Um
And he says he moves into
I we shouldn't feel sympathy. We should
feel less sympathy. Now that's nonsense.
That's nothing. You're not saying
anything when you say [__] [__] like
I have less sympathy if you do this.
That's not a position. It's not it's not
a take. It's not an argument. It's a
statement of emotion.
It's not something that can be logically
attacked. It's not something that can be
you know, undermined in any way. It is
your feeling and it is [__]
worthless. And you know someone is a
[__] [__] when they start watering
down their takes to the this level. So
in this topic, Lone Wolf Box is being a
total [__] [__] It is this absolute
just
cowardly position. We start talking
about oh I feel less sympathy. The Oreo
does it. Destiny does it. Sad to see
Lone Wolf Box doing it. Give a [__]
opinion. Say something that can be
attacked. It's so cowardly. So that's
that's the first thing. Now
let's attack the actual position.
So Lone Wolf Box thinks or wants to say
he wants to say this. He doesn't say
this. He wants to say this. He'd be
scared to. Lone Wolf Box thinks there
should be a social standard set that
you're not allowed to do malicious
reactions. Well, why not? If they're
transformative, who cares if you're
trying to attack the person's business?
If they're doing something wrong, you
should want to attack their business.
When you're reacting to Tim Pool, you
should want to deprive him of income
because he's a terrible [__] person
and he's doing terrible [__] Right?
You're trying to damage his business.
That's the goal. You want people to not
respect him. You want people to not
watch him. You want people to ignore
him.
So as long as you're actually producing
like a legitimately transformative piece
of content or engaging in like a fair
way, not necessarily good faith or not,
you know, malicious, but fair,
maybe you could even say fair use,
then then we're
we're fine with it.
That should be the standard. So [__]
this [__] idea of oh if we're doing
it maliciously, no. This is like
something that kind of makes sense in a
different example, non-political
examples or it's XQC watching a Lemon
video.
You can kind of make arguments here.
The idea though when you're talking
about political content, you should do
it without malicious intent. [__]
[__] [__] Next level [__]
stupid or drama content. So dumb.
Let's carry on. Especially with Casey
Tron because she literally
is a market replacement [__] machine.
>> [laughter]
>> So especially with Casey Tron
because she's a market replacement
machine. So because Casey Tron
has
uh infringed on copyright in the past,
it's okay for her to be sued here.
Not making a statement on this specific
case or why she's being sued here.
He's saying because of past actions, you
shouldn't care about this.
Again, [__] She's like a serial
market replacement machine. Um The thing
that's bugging me about it is like you
can hold Ethan to those standards and
you can correct him on it, but at the
end of the day when you look at the the
side that he's like up against like that
group like the Casey
>> Okay, so what has Casey Tron done to
Ethan?
What has Casey Tron done wrong to Ethan?
What has Denims done wrong to Ethan?
What has Frogan done wrong to Ethan?
Then once you answer that question,
which I don't think you really can,
you'll say something [__] You'll
say something [__] stupid like oh
well they associate with the Asons
community and that community has been so
and you're going to do some [__]
collective guilt guilt by association
[__] That's the first
Second thing you might do is Denims
justified CPS. She didn't. Third thing
you might do is Denims whole chat was
spamming spamming call CPS. No, it
wasn't. That's an edited clip that's
filtered down to include only the
messages about CPS and parenting from a
massive time span excluding like
thousands of other messages.
So we can walk down every talking point
you could potentially give and it's all
[__] [__] It's all total
[__] And let's say you managed to
find something. Let's say you find well,
Denims called Ethan a Zionist. And when
Denims says Zionist, what she means is
genocide supporter who wants Palestinian
kids to die.
Does that justify financial ruination?
No.
And you know it doesn't and they will
never lay out their full thinking. That
Lone All Lone Wolf Box will do for this
whole video is sit there and start
comparing it Israel-Palestine like
always saying, you know, giving his
analogy, oh well what you've got to
understand is yeah, sometimes when
you're in war, you don't know whether
the enemy combatant is like a civilian
or not. So you just have to shoot every
kid in the 50-mile radius. That's like
the sort of analogy that Lone Wolf Box
uses to try and excuse Ethan's behavior
here unironically. It's like he starts
sounding deranged about the other topic
because he's excusing so much. And
that's this whole video.
Casey Tron, Denims, all that. It's like
it's it's like you're
I don't know. It's just the
It's like you're watching two groups
fighting, okay? You're watching two
countries fighting and one side is just
firing chemical weapons
non-fucking stop all over the shop. And
then the other side gets a little bit
[__] pissy and drops like a tactical
nuke on like one part of their
installation. And you're like And then
the only thing you're talking about is
like the [__] tactical nuke that's
being used.
Um Oh yeah, that makes total sense.
Yeah, that makes total sense.
I think the behavior of the other side
is like kind of
the fact that they just like there's
nothing that holds them to account. Like
it doesn't matter how wrong they can be.
It doesn't matter how uh
>> What What do you mean they've been
They've received bans from Twitch.
Denims was banned for the Osama bin
Laden thing. They were all banned for
the for the Sabra hummus panel.
Do you mean they're not held to account
by anything?
You You have
done You have literally held them to
every possible account that content
creators are. Unless you just want them
permanently banned from everything.
They should literally just The only
acceptable solution is they are
permanently banned from everything.
They're all permanently banned from
everything.
Exactly, Ryan. What standards Ethan held
to by Lonerbox?
None. There are no standards for Ethan.
Every standard Ethan has set,
he has broken.
None of them care. All of them excuse
everything.
It is shameful.
There have not been standards for Ethan
in over 2 years.
And all of their actions can be or how
much
>> there have arguably never been standards
for Ethan. You can just go back and look
at how much of a scum [__] degenerate he
was for the entire Kavanaugh case.
And you can see it. You can see it
clearly. The idea that any of them,
Lonerbox, gets on stream with a straight
[__] face and goes, "Oh, so Ethan
doesn't do any of the stuff that Hasan
and Casey Tron and all these evil people
do?"
Yeah, maybe if you've only heard of
Ethan in the last year, you might not
think that. If you've only heard of
Ethan in the last year, and you believe
literally every deranged lie that he
tells about Hasan, because you're a
[__] compromised idiot, yeah, you
might think that. Yeah, you might think
that.
But Ethan has behaved like the most
reprehensible
dirt [__] scum piece of [__] by his
own standards for his entire career.
Calling Patrice Wilson a pedophile,
comparing Ryan Kavanaugh to Harvey
Weinstein, saying he runs a Ponzi
scheme, infringing on Traler's
copyright. It's
beyond a joke.
There are no standards for Ethan.
There are no standards. Lonerbox will
never hold him to account.
Hutch will never hold him to account.
The Oreos certainly will never hold him
to account.
Thank you, Juicy Dog, for the
membership. Thank you.
and call it out like it doesn't affect
them in the slightest. Like they have no
they're completely immune to all this
[__] So, at the end of the day, people
are going to use something and I guess
Ethan used the [__] copyright
lawsuit.
Oh, well, someone's going to do
something, so it's fine to just do it.
You You know, someone was going to rape
her anyway. You know, it's literally
dude, flashbacks to the Vaush argument.
There's a woman in a cage
in a cage in a restaurant and they say,
"Someone's going to rape the woman
anyway.
Someone's going to rape the woman
anyway. Someone's going to destroy Casey
Tron's life anyway. You know, Sony was
just going to come along and take Casey
Tron's house actually. It was going to
happen any day, so why not Ethan? What's
wrong with Ethan doing it?" [__]
idiot.
as example of Tim Pool is cuz it's your
claim that you don't give a [__] about
the motivations, the rationales. And so,
I'm trying to isolate that factor to
show actually, maybe if this was against
you or a person that you didn't quite
like suing, maybe actually you would
care about the motivation and whether
they're misrepresenting it. But But I
would never do something as stupid as
tell my audience, "Hey guys, you know,
watch me watch it so we can deprive Tim
Pool of a view." That's just idiotic.
Like they made themselves so vulnerable
by doing that.
by doing that. Why is that idiotic? Why
is that idiotic? Hutch is such a [__]
And notice how Lonerbox will sit here
Lonerbox just sits here ruminating about
the sweeping he's doing for Ethan, and
at no point gives actual commentary on
the obviously 60 IQ positions that Hutch
is taking here, where he's like saying,
"I just can't possibly engage with that
hypothetical. It's just so hard. I just
can't even possibly engage with it."
Like it's so funny, man. It's so funny.
So, what was Hutch saying here? What was
the statement he was making?
Yeah, so how is that stupid to do? It's
not part of the legal standard, so how
does it open you to any additional risk?
There is no reason to believe that
saying, "I'm maliciously reacting to
this," opens you to additional risk.
It's a purely manufactured reasoning
post hoc that Ethan has made up to try
and justify the lawsuits in the public
eye
and try and draw a distinction between
Denims and XQC.
Watch me watch it so we can deprive Tim
Pool of a view. That's just idiotic.
Like they made themselves so vulnerable
by doing Whether you would or
whether whether you would or not, it's a
hypothetical. Why are you fighting It It
literally It literally doesn't matter
cuz he set the trap, so he had decided
he was going to sue before they said
that stuff. There's no way they could he
could have known they were going to say
that stuff.
All that happened is
they reacted, came time to decide,
"Okay, I'm going to sue. I need to
target the people I'm against and not
the Asmongolds, the XQCs, and anyone
else. I need to come up with a standard
that I can apply to these people that
allows me to sue them and not the other
people. Okay, here it is. They said
this."
That's all it is. He would have come up
with some reason
if not that. And that's obvious to
anyone. It just logically has to be true
because he set the trap before knowing
they were ever going to say anything
like that.
So, it doesn't open you to any
additional risk. It There's no reason to
believe that.
swept up by this sort of lawsuit by a
creator if they really wanted to, Loner.
Like they made themselves so vulnerable
by doing
Whether whether whether you would
it's a hypothetical. Why are you
fighting? You could just as easily get
swept up by this sort of lawsuit by a
creator if they really wanted to, Loner.
Yeah, I know. Like the difference is
though is I don't use chemical weapons.
Like I don't I don't resort to [__]
lying about people.
>> it's in Ryan Bid's D4 Bid video. It's
It's at the end of that video. Or even
like
even the fact that like in terms of what
like what harassment ever comes from my
audience towards other people? My
audience are a bunch of [__] knitted
scarves. Like there's literally nothing
The worst thing that anyone can do to me
is prove me wrong about something. And
then my audience will feel [__]
embarrassed and be on my ass for it as
well. So, yeah, obviously I'm going to
feel like there's a slight a more
more like a more of an injustice if
someone comes after me and if I'm like
taking it You don't understand that.
It's It's You can't sue me cuz I'm a
good person, but Casey Tron's a bad
person, so you can't sue her. Tim Pool
and [__] on him. Yeah, you can
probably copyright me for that even if I
don't say it's marked or blatant, even
if I react, even if I react
meaningfully, even if I pause every 2
seconds. That can happen easily, right?
But I can do that. Um
and I would feel quite pissy about him
suing me and I'd think it's a bit
different to it coming to [__] like
someone like Casey Tron. And you know
it's different as well, you [__]
lying [__] Like you know it's
different. You're just pressed Like
you're trying to hold me to the exact
same [__] standard as people who are
Like you're just doing the
>> [laughter]
>> The exact same standards as people who
are what? What are they What are they
doing that means they should be held to
a different standard, Lonerbox? It's
people who are what? Just like total
short-circuited. Really, you think I
should be held to the same same
standards as them?
Yeah, have you got a reason why not?
Yeah?
Have you got Have you got a reason why
not, Lonerbox?
thing again where it's like you have to
hold me to the same standard as people
who break every single [__] like
social norm
>> are they doing? So, what are they doing?
So, what are they doing?
So, what have they done wrong? So,
No, I just I don't think that's serious
>> So, what norms do they break? So, wait.
What norms do they break? He's going to
He's going to give a specific example
here.
Surely this won't somehow turn into
another analogy about Israel-Palestine
that allows him to avoid saying anything
specific and just give generalities and
not cite anything happening in the
drama.
Surely he'll be Discord. Maybe he can be
normal again. Thank you for the $4.99.
Thank you. Yeah, I'd feel upset if
[__] Tim Pool sued me and I'd be in
big trouble and all that, but it's like
at the end of the day, like we all know
when we react to things that we are
liable to get attacked for that. We know
that like what we're doing can result in
someone coming to sue you. Um I just
don't, you know, tread in a way that's
really giving people much of a reason to
do it.
And that's just the social understanding
that we have.
Guys,
just don't piss Just don't piss off rich
and powerful people.
Don't piss off rich, powerful, spiteful
people.
Have you ever thought about just not not
not saying not being critical of people
more powerful than you?
Guys, I don't know if you know this,
but the way of the world is kind of, you
know, the strong will do as they please
and the the weak will suffer what they
must. I think you should probably figure
that out, guys.
I think I think you should probably
figure that out, don't you think?
Wow, great stuff, Loner. Wow, very Thank
you, Lonerbox. Thank you.
I see why you love Israel so much.
it. Yeah, Hutch even though again, I
super don't care. I I would say just
yeah, like regardless of whether or not
you would, what is your motivation here
and and and the motivation of Ethan? I
think it matters a little like what
would you do in this situation?
If I was dumb enough to say, "Hey guys,
watch me watch Tim Pool." Like I don't
know. I feel like Yeah, have you ever
thought about just like not dressing
like that? Like they they were dressed
They were basically asking for it. They
were basically asking for it. Yeah. It's
difficult for me to So, no bad tactics,
only bad targets. You are a
What What were they thinking? You know
Jeffrey Epstein's a pedophile, right?
And you just like
You just like took a massage job from
him.
[__] It was dumb enough to say, "Hey
guys, watch me watch Tim Pool." Like I
don't know. I feel like I I Yeah, it's
difficult for me to So, no bad tactics,
only bad targets. You are a [__]
idiot. Like you are so [__] stupid.
No bad tactics, only bad targets. It's
It's kind of like It's like
The problem with no bad tactics and only
bad targets.
[__] me, man. Hang on.
Short-circuiting, man.
He's short-circuiting.
>> with no bad tactics, only bad targets is
when one group unilaterally starts
Breaking down his phone. He's
short-circuiting. starts committing
every social faux pas
>> Sure, sure, sure. So, what did Casey
Tron do? What did Denims do?
What did Afro Gun do?
How are they breaking So, I understand,
right? If someone's like
you know, going crazy on
doxing and slander and [__] like I
understand sort of a bit of reciprocity.
I understand reciprocity as a concept.
That's not necessarily no bad tactics,
only bad targets if you have a standard
of reciprocity, right? That's not
necessarily no bad tactics, only bad
targets, as long as you're fully
justifying that. So, fully justify it.
Why is this reciprocal? It How is this
reciprocal? What have they done
to justify this?
Breaking every like or so it's
committing every social faux pas that
they can to deal with their like
opponents and then
I with no [__] prompting, right? No
bad tactics only bad targets is when
someone might come to someone like me
and think well, I you know, Learnabox he
doesn't really do personal attacks. He
doesn't really Guys, no bad tactics only
bad targets is when you go after me.
It's not when you go after my enemies.
Guys, when you go after me
that's no bad tactics only bad targets,
okay? When you go after my enemies,
that's just that's chill. That's chill.
That's chill. Wow, this is this is
sounding very intelligent. I'm not going
to lie. This is sounding like high-level
stuff.
This is very high-level stuff here.
What they do lying. He doesn't do any
um like defamation or underhanded
tactics against people, but we're just
going to use it against him because of
his ideology. You know, he's like a
valuable he's a valid target any means
necessary whatever the [__] Um but if I
start responding to someone with
underhanded tactics or things that like
like for example we
>> Yeah, so he's still on reciprocity
there, right? So yeah, redistricting
great example because they're available
to you.
That's reciprocity.
Now justify that in this context,
Learnabox. What are they doing? What are
they doing?
thing, right? If Gavin Newsom
unilaterally did redistricting when the
Republicans were playing fair and not
going against the Constitution and not I
was on an F.
Should be back.
reinterpreting every single law against
every precedent in American history to
get their way, then everyone would say,
"What are you doing? That's no bad
tactics only bad targets. What the [__]
is what what's the Why are you doing
this? You literally made it an
independent body for redistricting and
now you're taking it back into the
partisan sphere unilaterally, but
obviously if he's doing it in response
to Republicans doing it, that's
different." Whereas you would go to
Gavin Newsom like you understand this is
the person you are, right? You would go
to Gavin Newsom and say, "Oh, so No,
what what Learnabox, they want you to
say why is it justified, okay? So what
have they done?
What have they done? So no bad tactics
only bad targets.
>> the gerrymandering here, right? We see
we see from Ethan's side his
gerrymandering is copyright lawsuits
that could take the people's entire
[__] lives
to force them into
giving like recorded apology statements.
To force concessions from them, to force
speech out of them, to quell their
speech.
So what is their gerrymandering? What is
Denims doing? What is Frogan doing? What
is Casey Johnston doing?
Like why don't you rise above it, man?
Like
Yeah, you just want people to get
[__] raped. I don't know. You're just
[__] me. Agent hypothetical? Because I
wouldn't do something that [__] dumb.
Okay. Okay, then then let's if it's so
difficult to get hypothetical I'm going
to change one last thing. Yeah, he's a
true soul on his hill. The cognitive
dissonance is so obvious cuz you know
Learnabox is too smart to be saying this
[__] really.
The cognitive dissonance is so obvious.
He knows he's just like agitated because
he knows if he were to be honest, it's
like a [__] nightmare. It's like a
total [__] nightmare that he's in
this area with Ethan's [__] dick
riders as much he tries to taper some of
the edges of it sometimes.
It's become more and more apparent that
this is just
indefensible, but it's indefensible and
[__] and you've worked yourself into
a stupid position built on [__] lies
that you've been telling yourself for 2
years.
Yeah, Suppose that it were the case that
Ethan said, "I'm suing these people
because [__] them cuz I want them to
financially suffer and I want to ruin
them financially." And that was the
motivation. Would you give a [__]
I mean, it's not something that I would
do personally. Well, no, okay, but would
you think it's a good or a bad
>> asking whether you would personally do
it. I'm asking whether you think it's
good or bad. I don't know how to apply
labels to these kinds of thing. What?
Okay. Now that now I kind of get it.
It's a very easy like moral question. Do
you think it's okay to sue people cuz
you want to financially ruin them?
Uh well,
I don't know. It really depends on the
circumstances, right? Like what if that
person did to me? [clears throat]
Is there Ethan Klein sniper rifle
pointing at your forehead right now?
>> [laughter]
>> Yes, it depends. I think uh you know,
it's a situation
Guys, what what time is uh
Can someone keep an eye on the game
awards and tell
tell me when it's wrapping up and
getting to like whatever the world
premiere is. What the the the um
the Valve announce the alleged Valve
announcement. Cuz we'll tune in live for
that and then we'll watch the whole
thing on Kick.
What happens in but like I can't pick it
in here. Isn't that worse than comparing
this to a [__] war? Well, the point
of them not being the same is the point
of a comparison.
>> but Learnabox, you are using it as a
cop-out to avoid giving any actual
[__] details. Like that's a silly
thing to say in chat. That oh, don't use
an analogy. But Learnabox is using
analogies so that he doesn't have to
talk about the topic and it's very
[__] obvious. He can't talk about the
topic. He doesn't know why he thinks
these things are justified.
So he's avoiding it. So he just goes,
"Oh well, it's like Israel-Palestine.
It's like that thing we all agree on,
right guys? You can just shoot
Palestinian kids."
And it's an analogy. Like use your
What? It's really wrong to sue someone
to try to financially ruin them. All
right, can we can we pause for a second?
Is it is it not possible that Ethan
Ethan was motivated by two things? That
he has been consistently pushing against
>> I was so I'm so disappointed by this
video, man. By literally I was watching
this I was like, "Dude,
like you you are literally you are way
too smart to be talking this [__]
stupid and act like this much of a
[__] coward.
Take a position.
Talk about the topic.
Stop being a [__]
Let's just react to content where you
basically just do no effort, don't do
any kind of reaction and basically just
steal content. That he could be
motivated by both that and personal
grievance. Why does your audience hate
Pisco so much?
Um probably because a lot of them are
[__] Ethan fans. Yeah, it's the spot
of the video, yeah. Cuz they're [__]
side [__] [__] as well.
We try to keep them in line every now
and then, but you shouldn't hate Pisco.
What the [__]
You You ask is it possible? And what I
understand in is it possible question I
mean is it logically possible? By which
I mean does it does it entail a
contradiction?
>> to you that it could be both?
>> No, it does it does it does not it does
not look plausible to me. It does not
look plausible to me at all.
>> And time. That's the end of the drama
segment of Yeah, I I'm just going to
skip by this colon cuz Spider is
actually mentally disabled. Like that
guy should be in assisted living, I
think.
All right, I'm going to I'm going to see
if I can I can join back on. Okay, cool.
But I'm going to refresh my things to
rejoin, yeah.
Okay, got you. Based on that 10 minutes
conversation, all right, who won the
Ethan Klein drama slop debate?
>> [laughter]
>> Not enough time passed for a winner to
be declared
in my opinion. I have no idea what I
don't know the merits of either side. I
have no idea. Okay, well All I know is
Casey Johnston was horrifically
embarrassed.
Doesn't matter if she believed what she
read or not. The fact that she had to
read it was just
tragic to watch. It was it was pretty
sad. I don't know if anything was
accomplished by that, but I mean you
can't [__] with these big boys who have
money. Like this is kind of like America
in a nutshell. If you got money, you can
bring almost anyone to their knees, man.
Yeah, there's there's that excellent
John Oliver segment on SLAPP suits where
it's like they're just using it to
silence people. It's it's because I can
But please keep it up. Always speak the
truth. Also, do you like Black Sabbath?
Thank you for the $5. Really appreciate
it. Thank you. Uh Black Sabbath is like
okay, I guess.
It's like not too far in my mind from
your AC/DC. It's just like kind of
that that kind of classic rock that I
like. I don't I don't I wouldn't really
put it on generally.
I like Iron Man. I like Iron Man. That
is good that is that's a banger.
Thank you for the membership, Spinner
right? Thank you.
Thank you.
forward litigation lawyers. I'm going to
make your life a living hell regardless
of whether or not I'm justified in doing
so and I I think that's potentially a
bad thing we should do something about
it. I have no idea what the Ethan Klein
circumstances are.
>> Yeah, but don't care. But these Casey
Johnston and them needed to be smarter
about how they went after him and
they failed miserably so they can't
really cry foul.
>> is people can give me that like if you
want to make the argument for Ethan for
Denims or even Frogan, like you could
probably
I could probably quite easily convince
you of that. Even for Denims' case like
especially. I don't I don't think I ever
thought Denims was like one who deserved
like getting sued in the same way. You
realize So so like look, he dude, you
see how noncommittal all the statements
are?
I don't I could maybe be convinced on
that. I don't think I ever thought
Denims was like someone that like
deserved to get sued in like the same
way.
Do you think the lawsuit against Denims
is justified? Yes, no, why? Do you think
the lawsuit against Frogan is justified?
Yes, no, why?
Do you think the lawsuit against Casey
Johnston is justified? Yes, no, why?
Well, he's about to give us some of that
one. Okay, he's about to give us some of
that one. But his reasoning
Dude.
Is that Casey Johnston is above and
beyond when it comes to react stuff,
right? Like morally. We like there's no
one who is
>> Right, and that's that's Ethan's
reasoning for suing her, right guys? Cuz
she she reacted, right?
It's not because of the things she was
saying about A Moral because she's
associated with Hasan and Denims and
those other people. It's not to do with
that. It's got it's because of the react
thing. It's cuz of the react thing. All
right, that's what this was about.
That's not what that's not Ethan's logic
at all.
You know it's not.
Ethan sees Casey Johnston, XQC,
Asmongold, these people do about the
same thing.
There's not that much daylight between
them.
You know, I understand some XQC
maybe on average XQC's reactions are
slightly better than Casey Johnston's.
They both engage in the same flagrant
copyright violation.
And so does Learnabox.
And so does Learnabox. But we'll hear
why Learnabox thinks he's actually above
this. We'll hear why Learnabox is
actually above this, okay?
[__] moral frogging about the Casey
Johnston who who seriously believes even
when I was [__] playing Warcraft and
just [__] having videos on in the
background and not pausing that often.
Even that was like way above and beyond
anything Casey Johnston is doing. She
just literally she [__] just leaves
videos
There is no difference.
They all To be honest, there's no
difference in the content. To be honest,
I'll just say that. There's no
difference. But there's no difference
legally is what I was going to say.
There's no difference legally. Like
that's not a material material
difference legally.
You sitting there
watching
you know, whatever it is. The Rest is
Politics. I just say it cuz we were I
know we both love The Rest is Politics,
you know. Me and me and Luna Box. That's
why we love Luna Box, man. That's why we
love a great great podcast. Hey, hey,
hey.
Another reason why we love Luna Box.
You're sitting there playing World of
Warcraft Classic
wiping you know, wiping a level level 59
on hardcore.
You're playing World of Warcraft Classic
wiping at level 59 on hardcore dying to
balls at level 59.
on hardcore while watching The Rest is
Politics.
That's just as copyright infringing
as Casey Johnston sitting there you
know, [__] ripping a bong going,
"Oh, guys, I don't really get it. I
don't really get it."
every 20 minutes.
It's just You would both get sued. You
would both lose. They're both incredibly
strong claims if you get sued for that.
It's not a material [__] difference.
You're not drawing any serious standard
here. You're just like, "Oh, I just
really really don't like Casey
Johnston." is basically what you're
saying here.
Casey Johnston is just really really bad
with this. But there's no material
difference. There's no line you can
draw.
You're just like you really gives me
like when I see Casey Johnston do it, it
just looks even worse, you know. It just
looks even worse. Great stuff, man.
Seriously.
is on and leaves a [__] loop of
herself in the corner, which is not even
there, dude.
What are you talking about?
Then Ethan should sue xQc.
Welcome to civil law.
>> all they all share react to new [__]
they all share react.
They all do that [__]
>> Ethan is not the American
Ethan should sue xQc.
Welcome to civil law, idiot. Civil law
is you sue who you want to sue.
>> But the point is that his stated aim is
to protect copyright and protect the
react community.
Why is he not going after xQc if that's
the justification? Luna Box is using the
copyright infringement, the reacting,
the bad reactions as justification here.
So they are saying "Well, then why is he
not going after xQc and Asmongold if
that's the justification?"
It's not a matter of "Well, Ethan has
to sue everyone. He's required to sue
everyone." That's not what I'm trying to
say. Obviously, they're saying "If
copyright and the react content is the
justification how come he's not going
after xQc and Asmongold?" Hence, that's
not the justification. He's just doing
it cuz he doesn't like that group of
people.
You sue who you want to Ethan is not the
American
law is not the American legal system. If
you think that everyone should get sued
or no one gets sued, then make it a
criminal thing. Campaign to make
copyright a criminal case rather than a
civil
>> he's like totally not the point, [__]
Not the point, nice one, you [__]
idiot. Civil lawsuits are always going
to be based on whether or not someone
wants to sue someone. You understand
that, right? Yeah, and why does Ethan
want to sue them? Is it cuz of the
react? No, it's not, is it? Yeah, I mean
like Hutch that they literally said,
"I'm going to do the illegal thing like
on a live stream." So [laughter] it's
like all right, like it's not
>> That's not even that's not even the
worst thing for me. Like the worst thing
for me was the dog pile. Like like I
don't know, guy, if you're aware that
that CPS got called on on Ethan's like
kids and like the government showed up
to his home and
like I'm not accusing Yeah, go ahead.
Well, like you can't control everybody
in your audience doing crazy [__]
right? No, I'm and I'm not to be clear,
I'm not
>> by the creators.
>> It's just more evidence there's
motivation and spite than you're
admitting it. You're so [__] clever.
You're so clever. I don't know what like
did you just did you just have [__]
goo in your ears for the last 8 billion
times where I said that Ethan was doing
this to Casey Johnston? I was supposed
to say
>> So why are you using the copyright as a
justification? You can't draw a material
legal difference. You know it didn't
play any factor in Ethan's
decision-making. So why you bringing it
up as a justification? Simply because of
the harassment, because of those
communities. Yeah, of course he is.
That's how civil
Tell me how are civil suits not
How do they not imply
How do they not imply some degree of
spite? How? You have to make the choice
to sue someone. You can have 10 people
[__] you in a way that is civilly liable
or whatever. And it's your choice which
ones you sue. Obviously, say if one of
them is nicer to you or is
like maybe going to be have have more
resources and you don't want to go for
them or they just haven't given you much
of a reason to be upset with them. Of
course, you're going to sue the other
ones who are just being flagrant. It's
obviously it's a human suit.
>> So so you agree, Luna Box Ethan is lying
about his justification for suing these
people. It's actually spite based. And
the reason why he's not going after xQc
and Asmongold is because it would be a
strategically bad choice.
Because the goal is to destroy these
people for what they say and the people
they associate with.
So that's bad, right, Luna Box? So now
you agree with everyone else, right? Now
you Now you agree. Now you're on board,
right?
choice. That's why that's why we have
civil law.
>> [laughter]
>> To To be clear, I'm not accusing those
creators of like orchestrating that. I
do think that Denims was like wildly
irresponsible. There's one Hello, Spite
Air. Skip. Uh it's just that he he said
one thing
that is okay to do. Like it's as far as
you want to set like some kind of social
standard or a social precedent in the
streamer space, that makes sense. I
think it's what he stated a malicious
intent. It's not standard for choosing
to take the civil suit forward was
because they stated a malicious intent.
But that's not the social standard that
is set.
That is not the social standard that is
set. As Pisco has laid out a million
times so so brilliantly, you know.
xQc has stated malicious intent. He
doesn't state explicitly directed at
Ethan, but he has said acknowledged
that he knowingly willfully infringed on
copyright deliberately to make money. He
said it the whole way through. He's laid
out the malicious intent is all there.
So that's not the delineation. That
standard is not being set. The standard
that's being set is don't criticize
Ethan Klein while reacting to his
content. That's the social standard
that's set. And I think that is okay to
do. Like it's as far as you want to set
standard or a social precedent in the
streamer space, that makes sense. I
think it's it's it's probably okay to do
that. Like it
it
it's not going to be the legal it's not
going to be the legal precedent, but for
socially like I think it's fair.
Um but obviously, when he's saying that
it's going to protect other streamers
from Disney or whoever else who come in
with copyright suits
because it sets a precedent of malice
having to be the intent what the
what makes you liable. That's not true.
That's not going to change the law. Like
regardless of whether Ethan tries to set
a precedent of malice or not, it's not
going to change the fact that if you
have something registered and you
>> See, this is why I always have hope for
Luna Box, man, cuz you can see he just
can't bring himself to say the most
[__] thing.
You know, he can't bring himself to say
the most He can't bring himself to just
not analyze the law correctly.
You know?
This is why I always have hope for Luna
Box. Most people can just lie through
their teeth, okay? Luna Box clearly it
can't quite do that.
He can just be a total spineless wretch
for his entire segment.
copyright in terms of small claims
liability isn't if you do it, it doesn't
matter what your intent is. So he's
wrong when he's saying that.
>> listening? Is he still listening? Is he
still listening? Is he still listening?
Is he still listening?
So it's just I don't know why you get so
much and also the second argument to say
that these are mutually exclusive that
you're going after malicious intent, but
it's also because you don't like these
people. Why can't it be both? Why can't
it be that you don't like these people,
you want to sue them, but you also don't
want to do it in a way that looks that
basically
sets a social precedent that everyone
could just sue anyone.
Yeah, I mean there's been like DMCA DMCA
YouTube [__] like for a little while. So
I don't know why like people are all
like ass mad about this.
Um
with this situation.
Kind of weird.
Chill, man.
Do you think um
The armors I know no videos are coming
out before the end of the year. I'm
resigned to it, man. Nothing's happening
before the end of the year. It's all
next year now.
>> it's possible for like Ethan Klein to go
after like Hasan, probably or what? Um
probably not because again, that would
be He probably could legally, but
morally um
but that would obviously undermine his
standard because Hasan didn't express a
malicious intent. And Hasan was actually
asked to watch the video and he reacted
for like 9 hours. So that would be a big
overstep if he did it with Hasan
regardless of how much Hasan can defend
himself legally.
Yeah.
Interesting. Interesting. Interesting. I
don't know. I feel like
I don't know. I think Pisco I think feel
like I feel like Pisco Guys, do we know
what the stats on on the game was? I
don't know. Go [__] okay? I feel like
Ethan Klein should have went harder,
okay? [__] made Casey Johnston poor,
okay?
Wow,
great input, Spite Air.
I don't know why Pisco is doing the
whole [__] more grandstanding of like
>> This guy is
>> like legitimately disabled. Why don't
you call into stream?
Why don't you call into Pisco's stream
instead you go into Lonerbox's where
he's going to be, you know, kids gloves
with you?
Cuz he understands you're like 70 IQ,
total [__] drooler, but you clip his
[__] for free, so
you know.
What what what what's going to be What
can he do? What can he do?
[__] you're like, come on.
It's like cringe like that. It's just
weird cringe. Um
I don't know if I'm going to like Got to
roll a little, bro. Okay. Well,
take care.
All right. I don't know I'm going to
>> go to the J store or you can come in
here. particular stream or she
>> Maybe he won't cuz like I say he's
mentally disabled. He can't He kind of
knows that. He kind of knows that. He
kind of knows that he should probably be
living in a assisted living facility.
sort of like implying that it was
justified in this sort of thing, but
like the the the the massive dogpile
that that space like all the creators in
the Hassan orbit did with Ethan and Ela
was like one of the most disgusting
things that I've seen in all my years on
the internet.
I think Denims has turned out to be a
real dumb [__] with some of the things
she said. Uh she was praising Osama bin
Laden's uh
manifesto on her stream and then hearing
that she's praising CPS getting called
on somebody is ridiculous. So, she just
sounds like a real dumb [__]
All right, you heard it here, folks. We
are pro Denims is dumb on Live and
Learn. Let's go.
Well, it just shows you that not the the
smartest people don't always rise to the
top. In fact, some of the most mentally
unwell people tend to become the biggest
streamers.
>> aggressive Yeah, so that that's that
video, guys.
Dumbest Lonerbox video I've ever seen.
Literally so embarrassing for him.
He talks like this.
I know he can feel it, too. It's so
obvious. So,
it's just like, you know, I pray he sees
the light. I pray he sees the light.
Because he is literally [__] down to
the [__] core. There is no defense.
I love I love Lonerbox. I love Lonerbox.
You guys know. We love Lonerbox, in
fact. We all love Lonerbox.
So, uh I do I do have faith. I do have
faith.
Tech Tone is bigging up some gacha game,
apparently. What's this?
I bet this sucks, man. I know it's going
to suck.
Oh my god, yeah. It's [__] terrible.
Jesus Christ.
over-designed [__] [__]
Where's this? There is a some
Lonerbox takes on the
Venezuela stuff?
As they seized control of a massive oil
tanker off Venezuela's coast, word of
the mission You didn't respond to me cuz
you haven't [__] made one, you idiot.
Make an argument. Tell me Tell me why it
is bad to seize an oil tanker that is
being used to support the IRGC, to
support terrorist activity.
Tell me why that's bad.
Tell me why that's bad to not let these
[__] organizations fund to their
their practices.
>> [snorts]
>> I mean, is it not
that there's like zero basis in
international law for doing this?
Right? You
It's bad because the process hasn't been
followed?
No process has been followed?
It's just an It's just an act of
aggression against a
nearby country?
It's It's sort of like if um like can we
imagine maybe
if there was like a a massive super
powerful country that sort of like
outweighed all of its neighbors
and it said something like
um yeah, one of our neighboring
countries has a corrupt government
infiltrated by Nazis and they're using
it to fund
you know, their Nazi activities. So, we
need to do a special military operation
to go in and uh prevent uh uh aggression
from other international bodies and
denazify this region.
You know, like if someone said something
like that,
you'd probably be against it cuz it's
just like a bigger country
taking massive
steps to impede on the sovereignty
sovereignty [clears throat] of a a
smaller country
representing a massive a massive breach
of the the international rules-based
order.
That's what you might That's what you
might think about it in a different
situation. I don't I'm not quite sure
why it's not landing here.
Probably because they're communist or
something, I would guess.
Well, Hassan's Hassan's upset about
Trump attacking Venezuela, so uh